The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: We're
talking about tests.
And to be fair, we
spend most of our time
talking about new
jargon that we're using.
The main goal is to take a
binary decision, yes and no.
So just so that we're clear
and we make sure that we all
speak the same
language, let me just
remind you what the key
words are for tests.
So the first thing is
that we split theta
in theta 0 and theta 1.
Both are included in theta,
and they are disjoint.
So I have my set of
possible parameters.
And then I have theta 0
is here, theta 1 is here.
And there might be
something that I leave out.
And so what we're doing
is, we have two hypotheses.
So here's our hypothesis
testing problem.
And it's h0 theta belongs
to theta 0 versus h1 theta
belongs to theta 1.
This guy was called
the null, and this guy
was called the alternative.
And why we give
them special names
is because we saw that they
have an asymmetric role.
The null represents
the status quo,
and data is here to bring
evidence against this guy.
And we can really never
conclude that h0 is true
because all we could conclude is
that h1 is not true, or may not
be true.
So that was the first thing.
The second thing
was the hypothesis.
The third thing
is, what is a test?
Well, psi, it's a statistic,
and it takes the data,
and it maps it into 0 or 1.
And I didn't really mention it,
but there's some things such
as called randomized
tests, which is, well,
if I cannot really
make a decision,
I might as well flip a coin.
That tends to be biased,
but that's really--
I mean, think about
it in practice.
You probably don't
want to make decisions
based on flipping a coin.
And so what people
typically do--
this is happening, typically,
at one specific value.
So rather than flipping a coin
for this very specific value,
what people typically
do is they say,
OK, I'm going to side with
h0 because that's the most
conservative choice I can make.
So in a way, they think
of flipping this coin,
but always falling
on heads, say.
So associated to this test
was something called, well,
the rejection
region r psi, which
is just the set of data x1
xn such that psi of x1 xn
is equal to 1.
So that means we rejected
h0 when the test is 1.
And those are the
set of data points
that actually are going to
lead me to reject the test.
And then the things that
we're actually, slightly,
a little more important and
really peculiar to test,
specific to tests, were the
type I and type II error.
So the type I
error arises when--
so type I error is when you
reject, whereas h0 is correct.
And the type II error
is the opposite,
so it's failed to reject,
whereas h1 is correct--
h is correct, yeah.
So those are the two types
of errors you can make.
And we quantified their
probability of type I error.
So alpha psi is
the probability--
so that's the probability
of type I error.
So psi is just the probability
for theta that psi rejects
and that's defined
for theta and theta 0,
so for different
values of theta 0.
So h0 being correct means
there exists a theta in theta 0
for which that actually
is the right distribution.
So for different
values of theta,
I might make different errors.
So if you think, for example,
about the coin example,
I'm testing if the coin
is biased towards heads
or biased towards tails.
So if I'm testing
whether p is larger
than 1/2 or less than 1/2,
then when the true p-- let's
say our h0 is larger than 1/2.
When p is equal to 1, it's
actually very difficult for me
to make a mistake,
because I only see heads.
So when p is getting
closer to 1/2,
I'm going to start making more
and more probability of error.
And so the type II error-- so
that's the probability of type
II--
is denoted by beta psi.
And it's the function,
well, that does the opposite
and, this time, is defined
for theta in theta 1.
And finally, we define something
called the power, pi of psi.
And this time, this
is actually a number.
And so this number is equal to
the maximum over theta n theta
0.
I mean, that could be a
supremum, but think of it
as being a maximum of p
theta of psi is equal--
sorry, that's n0, right?
Give me one sec.
No, sorry, that's the min.
So this is not making a mistake.
Theta 0 is in theta 2 So
if theta is in theta 1
and I conclude 1, so
this is a good thing.
I want this number to be large.
And I'm looking at
the worst house--
what is the smallest
value this number can be?
So what I want to show you
a little bit is a picture.
So now I'm going to take theta,
and think of it as being a p.
So I'm going to take p for some
variable in the experiment.
So p can range between 0
and 1, that's for sure.
And what I'm going
to try to test
is whether p is less than
1/2 or larger than 1/2.
So this is going to
be, let's say, theta 0.
And this guy here is theta 1.
Just trying to give you a
picture of what those guys are.
So I have my y-axis, and now I'm
going to start drawing number.
All these things--
this function,
this function, and
this number-- are
all numbers between 0 and 1.
So now I'm claiming that--
so when I move
from left to right,
what is my probability
of rejecting going to do?
So what I'm going to plot is
the probability under theta.
The first thing I want to plot
is the probability under theta
that psi is equal to 1.
And let's say psi--
think of psi as being
just this indicator
that square root on n xn bar
minus p over square root xn
bar 1 minus xn bar is
larger than some constant c
for a probability chosen c.
So what we choose is that c
is in such a way that, at 1/2,
when we're testing
for 1/2, what we
wanted was this number to be
equal to alpha, basically.
So we fix this alpha
number so that this guy--
so if I want alpha of psi
of theta less than alpha
given in advanced--
so think of it as being
equal to, say, 5%.
So I'm fixing this
number, and I want
this to be controlled for
all theta and theta 0.
So if you're going to
give me this budget,
well, I'm actually going to
make it equal where I can.
If you're telling me you
can make it equal to alpha,
we know that if I
increase my type I error,
I'm going to decrease
my type II error.
If I start putting
everyone in jail
or if I start letting
everyone go free,
that's what we were
discussing last time.
So since we have this
trade-off and you're
giving me a budget for one guy,
I'm just going to max it out.
And where am I
going to max it out?
Exactly at 1/2 at the boundary.
So this is going to be 5%.
So what I know is that
since alpha of theta
is less than alpha
for all theta in theta
0-- sorry, that's for theta 0,
that's where alpha is defined.
So for theta and theta 0,
I knew that my function
is going to look like this.
It's going to be somewhere
in this rectangle.
Everybody agrees?
So this function for this guy
is going to look like this.
When I'm at 0, when
p is equal to 0,
which means I only
observe 0's, then I
know that p is going to be
0, and I will certainly not
conclude that p is equal to 1.
This test will never conclude
that p is equal to 1--
that p is larger than
1/2, just because xn bar
is going to be equal to 0.
Well, this is actually
not well-defined,
so maybe I need to do
something-- put it equal to 0
if xn bar is equal to 0.
So I guess, basically, I get
something which is negative,
and so it's never going to
be larger than what I want.
And so here, I'm
actually starting at 0.
So now, this is this function
here that increases--
I mean, it should
increase smoothly.
This function here is
alpha psi of theta--
or alpha psi of p, let's say,
because we're talking about p.
Then it reaches alpha here.
Now, when I go on
the other side,
I'm actually looking at beta.
When I'm on theta 1, the
function that matters
is the probability of type II
error, which is beta of psi.
And this beta of psi is
actually going to increase.
So beta of psi is what?
Well, beta of psi should also--
sorry, that's the probability
of being equal to alpha.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to look at the
probability of rejecting.
So let me draw this
functional all the way.
It's going to look like this.
Now here, if I look at
this function here or here,
this is the probability under
theta that psi is equal to 1.
And we just said
that, in this region,
this function is
called alpha of psi.
In that region, it's
not called alpha of psi.
It's not called anything.
It's just the
probability of rejection.
So it's not any
error, it's actually
what you should be doing.
What we're looking at in this
region is 1 minus this guy.
We're looking at the
probability of not rejecting.
So I need to actually,
basically, look at the 1
minus this thing, which
here is going to be 95%.
So I'm going to do 95%.
And this is my probability.
Ability And I'm just
basically drawing
the symmetric of this guy.
So this here is the
probability under theta
that psi is equal to 0,
which is 1 minus p theta
that psi is equal to 1.
So it's just 1 minus
the wide curve.
And it's actually,
by definition, equal
to beta of psi of theta.
Now, where do I read pi psi?
What is pi psi on this picture?
Is pi psi a number
or a function?
AUDIENCE: Number.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
It's a number, right?
It's the minimum of a function.
What is this function?
It's the probability under
theta that theta is equal to 1.
I drew this entire function for
between theta 0 and theta 1.
I drew-- this is this
entire white curve.
This is this probability.
Now I'm saying, look at the
smallest value this probability
can take on the set theta 1.
What is this?
This guy.
This is where my pi--
this thing here is pi psi,
and so it's equal to 5%.
So that's for this
particular test,
because this test has a
continuous curve for this psi.
And so if I want to
make sure that I'm
at 5% when I come to the
right of the theta 0,
if it touches theta
1, then I'd better
have 5% on the other side if
the function is continuous.
So basically, if
this function is
increasing, which will be
the case for most tests,
and continuous, then
what's going to happen
is that the level of the
test, which is alpha,
is actually going to be equal
to the power of the test.
Now, there's something
I didn't mention,
and I'm just mentioning
it passing by.
Here, I define the power itself.
This function, this
entire white curve here,
is actually called
the power function--
this thing.
That's the entire white curve.
And what you could
have is tests that
have the entire curve which
is dominated by another test.
So here, if I look
at this test--
and let's assume I can
build another test that
has this curve.
Let's say it's the same
here, but then here, it
looks like this.
What is the power of this test?
AUDIENCE: It's the same.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
It's the same.
It's 5%, because this
point touches here exactly
at the same point.
However, for any other value
than the worst possible,
this guy is doing
better than this guy.
Can you see that?
Having a curve higher
on the right-hand side
is a good thing because
it means that you
tend to reject more when
you're actually in h1.
So this guy is definitely
better than this guy.
And so what we
say, in this case,
is that the test
with the dashed line
is uniformly more powerful
than the other tests.
But we're not going to
go into those details
because, basically, all the
tests that we will describe
are already the
most powerful ones.
In particular, this guy is--
there's no such thing.
All the other guys
you can come up with
are going to actually be below.
So we saw a couple
tests, then we
saw how to pick this threshold,
and we defined those two
things.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yes?
AUDIENCE: But in that
case, the dashed line,
if it were also higher
in the region of theta 0,
do you still consider it better?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Because
you're given this budget of 5%.
So in this paradigm
where you're given the--
actually, if the dashed
line was this dashed line,
I would still be happy.
I mean, I don't care what
this thing does here,
as long as it's below 5%.
But here, I'm going
to try to discover.
Think about, again, the
drug discovery example.
You're trying to find--
let's say you're a scientist
and you're trying to prove
that your drug works.
What do you want to see?
Well, FDA puts on
you this constraint
that your probability of type
I error should never exceed 5%.
You're going to work
under this assumption.
But what you're going
to do is, you're
going to try to find a test that
will make you find something
as often as possible.
And so you're going to
max this constraint of 5%.
And then you're going to try to
make this curve, that means--
this is, basically, this
number here, for any point
here, is the probability
that you publish your paper.
That's the probability
that you can
release to market your drug.
That's the probability
that it works.
And so you want this curve
to be as high as possible.
You want to make sure that if
there's evidence in the data
that h1 is the truth, you
want to squeeze as much
of this evidence as possible.
And the test that has the
highest possible curve
is the most powerful one.
Now, you have to also understand
that having two curves that
are on top of each other
completely, everywhere,
is a rare phenomenon.
It's not always
the case that there
is a test that's uniformly more
powerful than any other test.
It might be that you
have some trade-off,
that it might be better
here, but then you're
losing power here.
Maybe it's-- I mean,
things like this.
Well, actually, maybe
it should not go down.
But let's say it goes like
this, and then, maybe, this guy
goes like this.
Then you have to, basically,
make an educated guess
whether you think that the theta
you're going to find is here
or is here, and then
you pick your test.
Any other question?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
the green curve again?
That's just the type II error?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So the
green curve is-- exactly.
So that's beta psi of theta.
So it's really
the type II error.
And it's defined only here.
So here, it's not
a definition, it's
really I'm just mapping
it to this point.
So it's defined only here,
and it's the probability
of type II error.
So here, it's pretty large.
I'm making it,
basically, as large
as I could because
I'm at the boundary,
and that means, at the boundary,
since the status quo is h0,
I'm always going
to go for h0 if I
don't have any evidence, which
means that what's going to pay
is the type II error that's
going to basically pay this.
Any other question?
So let's move on.
So did we do this?
No, I think we
stopped here, right?
I didn't cover that part.
So as I said, in
this paradigm, we're
going to actually fix
this guy to be something.
And this thing is actually
called the level of the test.
I'm sorry, this is,
again, more words.
Actually, the good news is that
we split it into two lectures.
So we have, what is a test?
What is a hypothesis?
What is the null?
What is the alternative?
What is the type I error?
What is the type II error?
And now, I'm telling you
there's another thing.
So we define the power, which
was some sort of a lower bound
on the--
or it's 1 minus the upper
bound on the type II
error, basically.
And so it's alternative--
so the power
is the smallest
probability of rejecting
when you're in the null.
And it's alternative when you're
in theta 1, so that's my power.
I looked here, and I looked
at the smallest value.
And I can look at this
side and say, well,
what is the largest probability
that I make a type I error?
Again, this largest probability
is the level of the test.
So this is alpha
equal, by definition,
to the maximum for theta in
theta 0 of alpha psi of theta.
So here, I just put
the level itself.
As you can see, here,
it essentially says
that if I'm of level of
5%, I'm also of level 10%,
I'm also of level 15%.
So here, it's really
an upper bound.
Whatever you guys want to
take, this is what it is.
But as we said, if
this number is 4.5%,
you're losing in
your type II error.
So if you're allowed to have--
if this maximum here is 4.5% and
FDA told you you can go to 5%,
you're losing in
your type II error.
So you actually
want to make sure
that this is the 5%
that's given to you.
So the way it works is
that you give me the alpha,
then I'm going to go back, pick
c that depends on alpha here,
so that this thing is
actually equal to 5%.
And so of course,
in many instances,
we do not know the probability.
We do not know how to compute
the probability of type I
error.
This is a maximum value for the
probability of type I error.
We don't know how to compute it.
I mean, it might be a very
complicated random variable.
Maybe it's a weird binomial.
We could compute it,
but it would be painful.
But we know how to compute
is its asymptotic value.
Just because of the central
limit theorem, convergence
and distribution tells me that
the probability of type I error
is basically going
towards the probability
that some Gaussian
is in some region.
And so we're going to
compute, not the level itself,
but the asymptotic level.
And that's basically
the limit as n
goes to infinity of
alpha psi of theta.
And then I'm going
to make the max here.
So how am I going
to compute this?
Well, if I take a test that has
rejection region of the form
tn--
because it depends on the
data, that's tn of x1 xn--
my observation's larger
than some number c.
Of course, I can
almost always write
tests like that,
except that sometimes,
it's going to be an absolute
value, which essentially means
I'm going away from some value.
Maybe, actually, I'm
less than something,
but I can always put a negative
sign in front of everything.
So this is not without
much of generality.
So this includes something
that looks like--
something is larger than the
constants, so that means--
which is equivalent to--
well, let me write that as tq,
because then that means that--
so that's tn.
But this actually
encompasses the fact
that qn is larger than c or qn
is less than c and n minus c.
So that includes this guy.
That also includes
qn less than c,
because this is equivalent
to qn is larger than minus c.
And minus qn is--
and so that's going to be my tn.
So I can actually encode
several type of things--
rejection regions.
So here, in this case, I
have a rejection region
that looks like this,
or a rejection region
that looks like
this, or a rejection
region that looks like this.
And here, I don't
really represent it
for the whole data, but maybe
for the average, for example,
or the normalized average.
So if I write this, then--
yeah.
And in this case,
this tn that shows up
is called test statistic.
I mean, this is
not set in stone.
Here, for example, q could
be the test statistic.
It doesn't have to
be minus q itself
that's the test statistic.
So what is the test statistic?
Well, it's what you're going
to build from your data
and then compare to
some fixed value.
So in the example we had here,
what is our test statistic?
Well, it's this guy.
This was our test statistic.
And is this thing a statistic?
What are the criteria
for a statistic?
What is the statistic?
I know you know the answer.
AUDIENCE: Measurable function.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
it's a measurable function
of the data that does not
depend on the parameter.
Is this guy a statistic?
AUDIENCE: It's not.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Let's think again.
When I implemented the
test, what did I do?
I was able to compute my test.
My test did not depend on
some unknown parameter.
How did we do it?
We just plugged in
0.5 here, remember?
That was the value for
which we computed it,
because under h0, that was
the value we're seeing.
And if theta 0 is
actually an entire set,
I'm just going to take the
value that's the closest to h1.
We'll see that in a second.
I mean, I did not
guarantee that to you.
But just taking the worst type
I error and bounded by alpha
is equivalent to taking p and
taking the value of p that's
the closest to theta 1, which
is completely intuitive.
The worst type I error is going
to be attained for the p that's
the closest to the alternative.
So even if the null is
actually just an entire set,
it's as if it was
just the point that's
the closest to the alternative.
So now we can compute
this, because there's
no unknown parameters
that shows up.
We replace p by 0.5.
And so that was
our test statistic.
So when you're
building a test, you
want to first build
a test statistic,
and then see what threshold
you should be getting.
So now, let's go back to our
example where we want to have--
we have x1 xn, their
IID [INAUDIBLE] p.
And I want to test if p is
1/2 versus p not equal to 1/2,
which, as I said, is what
you want to do if you
want to test if a coin is fair.
And so here, I'm going to
build a test statistic.
And we concluded
last time that--
what do we want
for this statistic?
We want it to have a
distribution which,
under the null, does not
depend on the parameters,
a distribution that I can
actually compute quintiles of.
So what we did
is, we said, well,
if I look at-- the central limit
theorem tells me that square
root of n xn bar
minus p divided by--
so if I do central limit theorem
plus Slutsky, for example,
I'm going to have square root.
And we've had this
discussion whether we want
to use Slutsky or not here.
But let's assume we're taking
Slutsky wherever we can.
So this thing tells me
that, by the central limit
theorem, as n goes to
infinity, this thing converges
in distribution to some n01.
Now, as we said, this guy
is not something we know.
But under the null,
we actually know it.
And we can actually
replace it by 1/2.
So this thing holds under h0.
When I write under h0, it
means when this is the truth.
So now I have something
that converges
to something that has no
dependence on anything I
don't know.
And in particular, if you have
any statistics textbook, which
you don't because I
didn't require one--
and you should be thankful,
because these things cost $350.
Actually, if you
look at the back,
you actually have a table
for a standard Gaussian.
I could have anything else here.
I could have an
exponential distribution.
I could have a--
I don't know-- well,
we'll see the chi squared
distribution in a minute.
Any distribution from
which you can actually
see a table that
somebody actually
computed this thing for
which you can actually
draw the pdf and start computing
whatever probability you want
on them, then this
is what you want
to see at the right-hand side.
This is any distribution.
It's called pivotal.
I think we've
mentioned that before.
Pivotal means it does
not depend on anything
that you don't know.
And maybe it's easy to
compute those things.
Probably, typically, you need
a computer to simulate them
for you because computing
probabilities for Gaussians
is not an easy thing.
We don't know how to solve
those integrals exactly,
we have to do it numerically.
So now I want to do this test.
My test statistic will
be declared to be what?
Well, I'm going
to reject if what
is larger than some number?
The absolute value of this guy.
So my test statistic
is going to be
square root of n minus 0.5
divided by square root of xn
bar 1 minus xn bar.
That's my test statistic,
absolute value of this guy,
because I want to reject either
when this guy is too large
or when this guy is too small.
I don't know ahead
whether I'm going
to see p larger than
1/2 or less than 1/2.
So now I need to compute c
such that the probability
that tn is larger than c.
So that's the probability
under p, which is unknown.
I want this probability to be
less than some level alpha,
asymptotically.
So I want the limit of this
guy to be less than alpha,
and that's the level of my test.
So that's the given level.
So I want this thing to happen.
Now, what I know is
that this limit--
actually, I should say
given asymptotic level.
So what is this thing?
Well, OK, that's the
probability that something
that looks like under p.
So under p, this guy--
so what I know is that
tn is square root of n
minus xn bar minus 0.5 divided
by square root of xn bar
1 minus xn bar exceeds.
Is this true that
as n to infinity,
this probability is the
same as the probability
that the absolute
value of a Gaussian
exceeds c of a
standard Gaussian?
Is this true?
AUDIENCE: The absolute value
of the standard Gaussian.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, the absolute.
So you're saying that this, as
n becomes large enough, this
should be the probability that
some absolute value of n01
exceeds c, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So I claim
that this is not correct.
Somebody tell me why.
AUDIENCE: Even in the
limit it's not correct?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Even in
the limit, it's not correct.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
So what do you see?
AUDIENCE: It's because,
at the beginning,
we picked the worst possible
true parameter, 0.5.
So we don't actually know
that this 0.5 is the mean.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Exactly.
So we pick this 0.5 here,
but this is for any p.
But what is the
only p I can get?
So what I want is that this
is true for all p in theta 0.
But the only p that's in theta
0 is actually p is equal to 0.5.
So yes, what you
said was true, but it
required to specify
p to be equal to 0.5.
So this, in general,
is not true.
But it happens to be true if
p belongs to theta 0, which
is strictly equivalent
to p is equal to 0.5,
because theta 0 is really
just this one point, 0.5.
So now, this becomes true.
And so what I need to
do is to find c such
that this guy is equal to what?
I mean, let's just follow.
So I want this to
be less than alpha.
But then we said that
this was equal to this,
which is equal to this.
So all I want is that this
guy is less than alpha.
But we said we might as well
just make it equal to alpha
if you allow me to make
it as big as I want,
as long as it's less than alpha.
AUDIENCE: So this
is a true statement.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So
this is a true statement.
But it's under this condition.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So I'm
going to set it equal to alpha,
and then I'm going to
try to solve for c.
So what I'm looking
for is a c such that
if I draw a standard Gaussian--
so that's pdf of some n01--
I want the probability that the
absolute value of my Gaussian
exceeding this guy--
so that means being
either here or here.
So that's minus c and c.
I want the sum of those two
things to be equal to alpha.
So I want the sum of these
areas to equal alpha.
So by symmetry,
each of them should
be equal to alpha over 2.
And so what I'm looking for
is c such that the probability
that my n01 exceeds c, which
is just this area to the right,
now, equals alpha, which is
equivalent to taking c, which
is q equals alpha over 2,
and that's q alpha over 2
by definition of q alpha over 2.
That's just what
q alpha over 2 is.
And that's what the tables at
the back of the book give you.
Who has already seen a table
for Gaussian probabilities?
What it does, it's just a table.
I mean, it's pretty ancient.
I mean, of course,
you can actually ask
Google to do it for you now.
I mean, it's basically
standard issue.
But back in the day, they
actually had to look at tables.
And since the values alphas
were pretty standard,
the values alpha that
people were requesting
were typically 1%,
5%, 10%, all you
could do is to compute
these different values
for different values of alpha.
That was it.
So there's really
not much to give you.
So for the Gaussian,
I can tell you
that alpha is equal to--
if alpha is equal to 5%,
then q alpha over 2, q 2.5%
is equal to 1.96, for example.
So those are just
fixed numbers that
are functions of the Gaussian.
So everybody agrees?
We've done that before for
our confidence intervals.
And so now we know
that if I actually
plug in this guy to be
q alpha over 2, then
this limit is actually
equal to alpha.
And so now I've actually
constrained this.
So q alpha over 2 here for alpha
equals 5%, as I said, is 1.96.
So in the example 1, the
number that we found was 3.54,
I think, or something
like that, 3.55 for t.
So if we scroll back
very quickly, 3.45--
that was example 1.
Example two-- negative 0.77.
So if I look at tn
in example 1, tn
was just the absolute
value of 3.45, which--
don't pull out your
calculators-- is equal to 3.45.
Example 2, absolute
value of negative 0.77
was equal to 0.77.
And so all I need to
check is, is this number
larger or smaller than 1.96?
That's what my
test ends up being.
So in example 1,
3.45 being larger
than 1.96, that
means that I reject.
Fairness of my
coins, in example 2,
0.77 being smaller than 1.96--
what do I do?
I fail to reject.
So here is a question.
In example 1, for what level
alpha would psi alpha--
OK, so here, what's
going to happen
if I start decreasing my level?
When I decrease my
level, I'm actually
making this area
smaller and smaller,
which means that I push
this c to the right.
So now I'm asking,
what is the smallest c
I should pick so that now,
I actually do not reject h0?
What is the smallest c
I should be taking here?
What is the smallest c?
So c here, in the example I
gave you for 5%, was 1.96.
What is the smallest c I
should be taking so that now,
this inequality is reversed?
3.45.
I ask only trivial
questions, don't be worried.
So 3.45 is the smallest
c that I'm actually
willing to tolerate.
So let's say this was my 5%.
If this was 2.5--
if here, let's say,
in this picture,
alpha is 5%, that means
maybe I need to push here.
And this number should be what?
So this is going to be 1.96.
And this number here is going
to be 3.45, clearly to scale.
And so now, what I
want to ask you is,
well, there's two ways I can
understand this number 3.45.
It is the number
3.45, but I can also
try to understand what is the
area to the right of this guy.
And if I understand what the
area to the right of this guy
is, this is actually
some alpha prime over 2.
And that means
that if I actually
fix this level alpha
prime, that would
be exactly the tipping
point at which I would
go from accepting to rejecting.
So I knew, in terms of
absolute thresholds,
3.45 is the trivial
answer to the question.
That's the tipping
point, because I'm
comparing a number to 3.45.
But now, if I try
to map this back
and understand what level
would have been giving me
this particular
tipping point, that's
a number between 0 and 1.
The smaller the number, the
larger this number here,
which means that the more
evidence I have in my data
against h0.
And so this number is actually
something called the p-value.
And so saying, for
example 2, there's
the tipping point
alpha at which I
go from failing to
reject to rejecting.
And that's exactly the number,
the area under the curve,
such that here, I see 0.77.
And this is this alpha
prime prime over 2.
Alpha prime prime is
clearly larger than 5%.
So what's the advantage of
thinking and mapping back
these numbers?
Well, now, I'm actually going
to spit out some number which
is between 0 and 1.
And that should be the only
scale you should have in mind.
Remember, we discussed
that last time.
I was like, well, if
I actually spit out
a number which is 3.45,
maybe you can try to think,
is 3.45 a large
number for a Gaussian?
That's a number.
But if I had another random
variable that was not Gaussian,
maybe it was a
double exponential,
you would have to have
another scale in your mind.
Is 3.45 so large that
it's unlikely for it
to come from a
double exponential.
If I had a gamma distribution--
I can think of any distribution,
and then that means,
for each distribution, you would
have to have scale in mind.
So of course, you can have
the Gaussian scale in mind.
I mean, I have the
Gaussian scale in mind.
But then, if I map it back into
this number between 0 and 1,
all the distributions
play the same role.
So whether I'm talking about
if my limiting distribution is
normal or exponential or
gamma, or whatever you want,
for all these guys,
I'm just going
to map it into one
number between 0 and 1.
Small number means lots
of evidence against h1.
Large number means lots
of evidence against h0.
Small number means very
few evidence against h9.
And this is the only number
you need to keep in mind.
And the question
is, am I willing
to tolerate this number between
5%, 6%, or maybe 10%, 12%?
And this is the only scale
you have to have in mind.
And this scale is the
scale of p-values.
So the p-value is the tipping
point in terms of alpha.
In words, I can make it
formal, because tipping point,
as far as I know, is
not a mathematical term.
So a p-value of a
test is the smallest,
potentially asymptotic level
if I talk about an asymptotic
p-value--
and that's what we do when we
talk about central theorem--
at which the test rejects h0.
If I were to go any smaller--
sorry, it's the smallest level--
yeah, if I were
to go any smaller,
I would fail to reject.
The smaller the level, the less
likely it is for me to reject.
And if I were to
go any smaller, I
would start failing to reject.
And so it is a random number.
It depends on what
I actually observe.
So here, of course, I
instantiated those two numbers,
3.45 and 0.77, as realizations
of random variables.
But if you think of those
as being the random numbers
before I see my data,
this was a random number,
and therefore, the area under
the curve to the right of it
is also a random area.
If this thing fluctuates,
then the area under the curve
fluctuates.
And that's what the p-value is.
That's what-- what is his name?
I forget.
John Oliver talks about when
he talks about p-hacking.
And so we talked about
this in the first lecture.
So p-hacking is, how do I
do-- oh, if I'm a scientist,
do I want to see a small
p-value or a large p-value?
AUDIENCE: Small.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Small, right?
Scientists want to see small
p-values because small p-values
equals rejecting,
which equals discovery,
which equals publications,
which equals promotion.
So that's what
people want to see.
So people are tempted
to see small p-values.
And what's called p-hacking
is, well, find a way to cheat.
Maybe look at your data,
formulate your hypothesis
in such a way that you will
actually have a smaller
p-value than you should have.
So here, for example,
there's one thing
I did not insist on
because, again, this is not
a particular course on
statistical thinking,
but one thing that
we implicitly did
was set those theta 0 and
theta 1 ahead of time.
I fixed them, and I'm
trying to test this.
This is to be contrasted
with the following approach.
I draw my data.
So I draw--
I run this experiment,
which is probably
going to get me a
publication in nature.
I'm trying to test
if a coin is fair.
And I draw my data,
and I see that there's
13 out of 30 of my
observations that are heads.
That means that,
from this data, it
looks like p is less than 1/2.
So if I look at
this data and then
decide that my alternative
is not p not equal to 1/2,
but rather p less than
1/2, that's p-hacking.
I'm actually making my
p-value strictly smaller
by first looking at the
data, and then deciding what
my alternative is going to be.
And that's cheating, because
all the things we did,
we're assuming that this
0.5, or the alternative,
was actually a fixed--
everything was deterministic.
The only randomness
came from the data.
But if I start
looking at the data
and designing my experiment
or my alternatives
and null hypothesis
based on the data,
it's as if I started putting
randomness all over the place.
And then I cannot control it
because I don't know how it
just intermingles
with each other.
So that was for the
John Oliver moment.
So the p-value is nice.
So maybe I mentioned
that, before, my wife
works in market research.
And maybe every two
years, she seems
to run into a statistician
in the hallway,
and she comes home and says,
what is a p-value again?
And for her, a p-value
is just the number
in an Excel spreadsheet.
And actually, small equals
good and large equals bad.
And that's all she needs
to know at this point.
Actually, they do the job
for her-- small is green,
large is red.
And so for her, a p-value
is just green or red.
But so what she's
really implicitly doing
with this color code is just
applying the golden rule.
What the statisticians do for
her in the Excel spreadsheet
is that they take the
numbers for the p-values that
are less than some fixed level.
So depending on the field
in which she works--
so she works for
pharmaceutical companies--
so the p-values are
typically compared--
the tests are usually performed
at level 1%, rather than 5%.
So 5% is maybe
your gold standard
if you're doing
sociology or trying to--
I don't know-- release
a new blueberry flavor
for your toothpaste.
Something that's not going
to change the life of people,
maybe you're going to run at 5%.
It's OK to make a mistake.
See, people are just
going to feel gross,
but that's about
it, whereas here,
if you have this p-value
which is less than 1%,
it might be more important
for some drug discovery,
for example.
And so let's say you run at 1%.
And so what they do in
this Excel spreadsheet is
that all the numbers that
are below 1% show up in green
and all the numbers that
are above 1% show up in red.
And that's it.
That's just applying
the golden rule.
If the number is green, reject.
If the number is
red, fail to reject.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So going
back to example 2
where the prior
example where you
want to cheat by
looking after beta
and then formulating, say,
theta 1 to be p less than 1/2.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how would
you achieve your goal
by changing the theta--
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
By achieving my goal,
you mean letting
ethics aside, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Ah,
you want to be published.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: [LAUGHS]
So let me teach you how, then.
So well, here, what do you do?
You want to-- at
the end of the day,
a test is only telling you
whether you found evidence
in your data that h1 was more
likely than h0, basically.
How do you make h1 more likely?
Well, you just basically
target h1 to be what it is--
what the data is going to
make it more likely to be.
So if, for example, I say
h1 can be on both sides,
then my data is going to have to
take into account fluctuations
on both sides, and I'm going to
lose a factor or two somewhere
because things
are not symmetric.
Here is the ultimate
way of making this work.
I'm going back to my
example of flipping coins.
And now, so here,
what I did is, I said,
oh, this number 0.43 is
actually smaller than 0.5,
so I'm just going to
test whether I'm 0.5
or I'm less than 0.5.
But here is something
that I can promise you
I did not make the
computation will reject.
So here, this one actually--
yeah, this one fails to reject.
So here is one that
will certainly reject.
h0 is 0.5, p is
0.5, h1p is 0.43.
Now, you can try,
but I can promise you
that your data will tell you
that h1 is the right one.
I mean, you can check very
quickly that this is really
extremely likely to happen.
Actually, what am I--
no, actually, that's
not true, because here,
the test that I derive that's
based on this kind of stuff,
here at some point,
somewhere under some layers,
I assume that all our tests
are going to have this form.
But here, this is
only when you're
trying to test one region versus
another region next to it,
or one point versus
a region around it,
or something like this,
whereas for this guy,
there's another test
that could come up with,
which is, what is the
probability that I get 0.43,
and what is the
probability that I get 0.5?
Now, what I'm
going to do is, I'm
going to just conclude
it's whichever
has the largest probability.
Then maybe I'm going to have
to make some adjustments so
that the level is actually 5%.
But I can make this happen.
I can make the level be 5%
and always conclude this guy,
but I would have to
use a different test.
Now, the test that
I described, again,
those tn larger
than c are built in
to be tests that are resilient
to these kind of manipulations
because they're
oblivious towards what
the alternative looks like.
I mean, they're just saying
it's either to the left
or to the right,
but whether it's
a point or an entire
half-line doesn't matter.
So if you try to
look at your data
and just put the data itself
into your hypothesis testing
problem, then you're failing
the statistical principle.
And that's what
people are doing.
I mean, how can I check?
I mean, of course,
here, it's going
to be pretty blatant
if you publish
a paper that looks like this.
But there's ways to
do it differently.
For example, one way to
do it is to just do mult--
so typically, what
people do is they
do multiple hypothesis testing.
They're doing 100
tests at a time.
Then you have random
fluctuations every time.
And so they just
pick the one that
has the random fluctuations
that go their way.
I mean, sometimes it's
going in your way,
and sometimes it's
going the opposite way,
so you just pick the
one that works for you.
We'll talk about multiple
hypothesis testing soon
if you want to increase
your publication count.
There's actually papers--
I think it was a big
news that some papers,
I think, in psychology
or psychometrics
papers that actually refused
to publish p-values now.
Where were we?
Here's the golden rule.
So one thing that I like
to show is this thing,
just so you know how you
apply the golden rule
and how you apply
the standard tests.
So the standard paradigm
is the following.
You have a black box,
which is your test.
For my wife, this is the
4th floor of the building.
That's where the
statisticians sit.
What she sends there is data--
let's say x1 xn.
And she says, well, this
one is about toothpaste,
so here's a level--
let's say 5%.
What the 4th floor brings
back is that answer-- yes,
no, green, red, just an answer.
So that's the standard testing.
You just feed it the data
and the level at which you
want to perform the
test, maybe asymptotic,
and it spits out
a yes, no answer.
What p-value does, you just
feed it the data itself.
And what it spits
out is the p-value.
And now it's just up to you.
I mean, hopefully your brain
has the computational power
of deciding whether a number
is larger or smaller than 5%
without having to call
a statistician for this.
And that's what it does.
So now we're on 1 scale.
Now, I see some of you nodding
when I talk about p-hacking,
so that means you've
seen p-values.
If you've seen more than
100 p-values in your life,
you have an entire scale.
A good p-value is less
than 10 to the minus 4.
That's the ultimate sweet spot.
Actually, statistical
software spits out
an output which says less
than 10 to the minus 4.
But then maybe
you want a p-val--
if you tell me my p-value
was 4.65, then I will say,
you've been doing some
p-hacking until you found
a number that was below 5%.
That's typically
what people will do.
But if you tell me--
if you're doing the
test, if you're saying,
I published my
result, my test at 5%
said yes, that means that
maybe you're p-value was 4.99,
or you're p-value was 10 to
the minus 4, I will never know.
I will never know
how much evidence
you had against the null.
But if you tell me
what the p-value is,
I can make my own decision.
I don't have to tell me
whether it's a yes, no.
You tell me it's 4.99, I'm
going to say, well, maybe yes,
but I'm going to take
it with a grain of salt.
And so that's why p-values are
good numbers to have in mind.
Now, I should, as if it
was like an old trick
that you start mastering
when you're 45 years old.
No, it's just, how small is
the number between 0 and 1?
That's really what
you need to know.
Maybe on the log scale--
if it's 10 to the minus 1,
10 to the minus 2, 10 to
the minus 3, et cetera--
that's probably the extent
of the mastery here.
So this traditional standard
paradigm that I showed
is actually commonly referred to
as the Neyman-Pearson paradigm.
So here, it says name
Neyman-Pearson's theory,
so there's an entire
theory that comes with it.
But it's really a paradigm.
It's a way of thinking about
hypothesis testing that
says, well, if I'm not going
to be able to optimize both
my type I and type II
error, I'm actually
going to lock in my type
I error below some level
and just minimize the type II
error under this constraint.
That's what the
Neyman-Pearson paradigm is.
And it sort of makes sense for
hypothesis testing problems.
Now, if you were doing
some other applications
with multi-objective
optimization,
you would maybe come up
with something different.
For example, machine learning
is not performing typically
under Neyman-Pearson paradigm.
So if you do spam filtering,
you could say, well,
I want to constrain the
probability as much as I can
of taking somebody's
important emails
and throwing them out as spam,
and under this constraint,
not send too much
spam to that person.
That sort of makes
sense for spams.
Now, if you're labeling cats
versus dogs, that's probably
not like you want to make
sure that no more than 5%
of the dogs are labeled
cat because, I mean,
it doesn't matter.
So what you typically
do is, you just
sum up the two types
of errors you can make,
and you minimize the sum
without putting any more
weight on one or the other.
So here's an example where doing
a binary decision, one or two
of the errors you
can make, you don't
have to actually be like that.
So this example here, I did not.
The trivial test psi is
equal to 0, what was it
in the US trial court example?
What is psi equals 0?
That was concluding
always to the null.
What was the null?
AUDIENCE: Innocent.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Innocent, right?
That's the status quo.
So that means that this
guy never rejects h0.
Everybody's going away free.
So you're sure
you're not actually
going against the constitution
because alpha is 0%, which
is certainly less than 5%.
But the power, the fact
that a lot of criminals
go back outside
in the free world
is actually formulated in
terms of low power, which,
in this case, is actually 0.
Again, the power is the
number between 0 and 1.
Close to 0, good.
Close to 1, bad.
Now, what is the
definition of the p-value?
That's going to be
something-- it's a mouthful.
The definition of the
p-value is a mouthful.
It's the tipping point.
It is the smallest level at
which blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah.
It's complicated to remember it.
Now, I think that my 6th
explanation, my wife,
after saying, oh, so it's the
probability of making an error,
I said, yeah, that's the
probability of making
an error because,
of course, she can
think probability of making an
error small, good, large, bad.
So that's actually a
good way to remember.
I'm pretty sure
that at least 50%
of people who are using
p-values out there
think that the p-value is the
probability of making an error.
Now, for all
matters of purposes,
if your goal is to just
threshold the p-value,
this is OK to have this in y.
But when comes, at
least until December 22,
I would recommend trying
to actually memorize
the right definition
for the p-value.
So the idea, again,
is fix the level
and try to optimize the power.
So we're going to try to compute
some p-values from now on.
How do you compute the p-value?
Well, you can actually see it
from this picture over there.
One thing I didn't show
on this picture-- so here,
it was my q alpha over
2 that had alpha here,
alpha over 2 here.
That was my q alpha over 2.
And I said, if tn is to
the right of this guy,
I'm going to reject.
If tn is to the
left of this guy,
I'm going to fail to reject.
Pictorially, you can actually
represent the p-value.
It's when I replace
this guy by tn itself.
Sorry, that's p-value over 2.
No, actually, that's p-value.
So let me just keep it like
that and put the absolute value
here.
So if you replace the role of
q alpha over 2, by your test
statistic, the area
under the curve
is actually the
p-value itself up
to a scale because of
the symmetric thing.
So there's a good way
to see, pictorially,
what the p-value is.
It's just the probability
that some Gaussians--
it's just the probability that
some absolute value of n01
exceeds tn.
That's what the p-value is.
Now, this guy has nothing
to do with this guy,
so this is really just 1
minus the Gaussian cdf of tn,
and that's it.
So that's how I would
compute p-values.
Now, as I said, the
p-value is a beauty
because you don't
have to understand
the fact that your limiting
distribution is a Gaussian.
It's already factored
in this construction.
The fact that I'm
actually looking
at this cumulative distribution
function of a standard Gaussian
makes my p-value
automatically adjust to what
the limiting distribution is.
And if this was the
cumulative distribution
function of a
exponential, I would just
have a different function here
denoted by f, for example,
and I would just compute
a different value.
But in the end, regardless of
what the limiting value is,
my p-value would still be
a number between 0 and 1.
And so to illustrate
that, let's look
at other weird distributions
that we could get in place
of the standard Gaussian.
And we're not going to see
many, but we'll see one.
And it's not called the
chi squared distribution.
It's actually called the
Student's distribution,
but it involves the chi
squared distribution
as a building block.
So I don't know if my phonetics
are not really right there,
so I try to say, well,
it's chi squared.
Maybe it's "kee" squared
above, in Canada, who knows.
So for a positive integer,
so there's only 1 parameter.
So for the Gaussian,
you have 2 parameters,
which are mu and sigma squared.
Those are real numbers.
Sigma squared's positive.
Here, I have 1
integer parameter.
Then the chi
squared distribution
with d degrees of freedom--
so the parameter is called
a degree of freedom,
just like mu is called the
expected value and sigma
squared is called the variance.
Here, we call it
degrees of freedom.
You don't have to
really understand why.
So that's the law
that you would get--
that's the random
variable you would
get if you were to sum d
squares of independent standard
Gaussians.
So I take the square of an
independent random Gaussian.
I take another one.
I sum them, and
that's a chi squared
with 2 degrees of freedom.
That's how you get it.
Now, I could define it using its
probability density function.
I mean, after all,
this is the sum
of positive random
variables, so it
is a positive random variable.
It has a density on
the positive real line.
And the pdf of chi squared with
d degrees of freedom is what?
Well, it's fd of x is--
what is it?-- x to the d/2
minus 1 e to the minus x/2.
And then here, I
have a gamma of d/2.
And the other one is, I
think, 2 to the d/2 minus 1.
No, 2 to the d/2.
That's what it is.
That's the density.
If you are very
good at probability,
you can make the
change of variable
and write your Jacobian
and do all this stuff
and actually check
that this is true.
I do not recommend doing that.
So this is the density, but it's
better understood like that.
I think it was just
something that you
built from standard Gaussian.
So for example, an
example of a chi
squared with 2
degrees of freedom
is actually the following thing.
Let's assume I have
a target like this.
And I don't aim very well.
And I'm trying to
hit the center.
And I'm not going
to have, maybe,
a deviation, which is
standard Gaussian left, right
and standard Gaussian
north, south.
So I'm throwing,
and then I'm here,
and I'm claiming that this
number here, by Pythagoras
theorem, the square
distance here
is the sum of this
square distance
here, which is the square
of a Gaussian by assumption.
This is plus the square
of this distance,
which is the square of
another independent Gaussian.
I assume those are independent.
And so the square distance
from this point to this point
is the chi squared with
2 degrees of freedom.
So this guy here is n01 squared.
This is n01 squared.
And so this guy here,
this distance here,
is chi squared with
2 degrees of freedom.
I mean the square distance.
I'm talking about
square distances here.
So now you can see that,
actually, Pythagoras
is basically why chi
squared [? arrives. ?]
That's why it has its own name.
I mean, I could define
this random variable.
I mean, it's actually
a gamma distribution.
It's a special case of something
called the gamma distribution.
The fact that the special
case has its own name
is because there's
many times what
we're going to
take sum of squares
of independent Gaussians because
Gaussians, the sum of squares
is really the norm, the
Euclidean norm squared,
just by Pythagoras theorem.
If I'm in higher
dimension, I can
start to sum more
squared coordinates,
and I'm going to measure
the norm squared.
So if you want to draw this
picture, it looks like this.
Again, it's the sum
of positive numbers,
so it's going to be
on 0 plus infinity.
That's fd.
And so f1 looks like
this, f2 looks like this.
So the tails become heavier
and heavier as d increases.
And then at [INAUDIBLE]
to 3, it starts
to have a different shape.
It starts from 0 and
it looks like this.
And then, as d
increases, it's basically
as if you were to push
this thing to the right.
It's just like, psh, so it's
just falling like a big blob.
Everybody sees what's going on?
So there's just this fat
thing that's just going there.
What is the expected
value of a chi squared?
So it's the expected
value of the sum
of Gaussian random
variables, squared.
I know I said that.
AUDIENCE: So it's the sum of
their second moments, right?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Which is?
Those are n01.
AUDIENCE: It's
like-- oh, I see, 1.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So n times
1 or d times 1.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, which is d.
So one thing you
can check quickly
is that the expected value
of a chi squared is d.
And so you see, that's why the
mass is shifting to the right
as d increases.
It's just going there.
Actually, the variance
is also increasing.
The variance is 2d.
So this is one thing.
And so why do we
care about this?
In basic statistics,
it's not like we actually
have statistics much
about throwing darts
at high-dimensional boards.
So what's happening is that if
I look at the sample variance,
the average of the sum of
squared centered by their mean,
then I can actually
expend this as the sum
of the squares minus
the average squared
It's just the same
trick that we have
for the variance-- second moment
minus first moment square.
And then I claim that
Cochran's theorem--
and I will tell you in a second
what Cochran's theorem tells me
is that this sample
variance is actually--
so if I had only this--
look at those guys.
Those guys are Gaussian
with mean mu and variance
sigma squared.
Think for 1 second mu being
0 and sigma squared being 1.
Now, this part would be a
chi squared with n degrees
of freedom divided by n.
Now I get another
thing here, which
is the square of something that
looks like a Gaussian as well.
So it looks like I have
something else here, which
looks also like a chi squared.
Now, Cochran's theorem is
essentially telling you
that those things
are independent,
and so that in a way, you can
think of those guys as being,
here, n degrees of freedom
minus 1 degree of freedom.
Now, here, as I said, this
does not mean 0 and variance 1.
The fact that it's not
mean 0 is not a problem
because I can remove the mean
here and remove the mean here.
And so this thing has
the same distribution,
regardless of what
the actual mean is.
So without loss of
generality, I can
assume that mu is equal to 0.
Now, the variance, I'm
going to have to pay,
because if I multiply
all these numbers by 10,
then this sn is going
to multiplied by 100.
So this thing is going to
scale with the variance.
And not surprisingly, it's
scaling like the square
of the variance.
So if I look at sn,
it's distributed
as sigma squared
times the chi squared
with n minus 1 degrees
of freedom divided by n.
And we don't really write
that, because a chi squared
times sigma squared divided
by n is not a distribution,
so we put everything
to the left,
and we say that this is
actually a chi squared with n
minus 1 degrees of freedom.
So here, I'm actually
dropping a fact on you,
but you can see
the building block.
What is the thing that's
fuzzy at this point,
but the rest should be
crystal clear to you?
The thing that's fuzzy is
that removing this squared guy
here is actually removing
1 degree of freedom.
That should be weird, but that's
what Cochran's theorem tells.
It's essentially
stating something
about orthogonality of
subspaces with the span
of the constant vector,
something like that.
So you don't have to
think about it too much,
but that's what it's telling me.
But the rest, if you plug in--
so the scaling in sigma squared
and in n, so that should
be completely clear to you.
So in particular, if
I remove that part,
it should be clear to you
that this thing, if mean is 0,
this thing is
actually distributed.
Well, if mu is 0, what is
the distribution of this guy?
So I remove that
part, just this part.
So I have xi, which
are n0 sigma squared.
And I'm asking, what is the
distribution of 1/n sum from i
equal 1 to n of xi squared?
So it is the sum of their IID.
So it's the sum of independent
Gaussians, but not standard.
So the first thing
to make them standard
is that I divide all of
them by sigma squared.
Now, this guy is of the form
zi squared where zi is n01.
So now, this thing here
has what distribution?
AUDIENCE: Chi squared n.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Chi squared n.
And now, sigma squared over
n times chi squared n--
so if I have sigma squared
divided by n times chi
squared--
sorry, so n times n
divided by sigma squared.
So if I take this
thing and I multiply it
by n divided by sigma squared,
it means I remove this term,
and now I am left
with a chi squared
with n degrees of freedom.
Now, the effect of centering
with the sample mean here
is only to lose 1
degree of freedom.
That's it.
So if I want to do a test
about variance, since this
is supposedly a good
estimator of variance,
this could be my
pivotal distribution.
This could play the
role of a Gaussian.
If I want to know if my variance
is equal to 1 or larger than 1,
I could actually build a test
based on this only statement
and test if the variance
is larger than 1 or not.
Now, this is not
asymptotic because I
started with the very
assumption that my data was
Gaussian itself.
Now, just a side
remark-- you can
check that this chi squared 2,
2 is an exponential with 1/2
degrees of freedom,
which is certainly not
clear from the fact that
z1 squared plus z2 squared
is a chi squared with
2 degrees of freedom.
if I give you the
sum of the square
of 2 independent Gaussian, this
is actually an exponential.
That's not super clear, right?
But if you look
at what was here--
I don't know if you took notes,
but let me rewrite it for you.
So it was x to the d/2 minus
1 e to the minus x/2 divided
by 2 to the d/2 gamma of d/2.
So if I plug in d is
equal to 2, gamma of 2/2
is gamma of 1, which is 1.
It's factorial of 0.
So it's 1, so this
guy goes away.
2 to the d/2 is 2 to
1, so that's just 1.
No, that's just 2.
Then x the d/2 minus 1
is x the 0, goes away.
And so I have x minus x/2
1/2, which is really, indeed,
of the form lambda e
to the minus lambda
x for lambda is equal
to 1/2, which was
our exponential distribution.
Well, next week is,
well, Columbus Day?
So not next Monday--
so next week, we'll talk
about Student's distribution.
And so that was
discovered by a guy
who pretended his name was
Student, but was not Student.
And I challenge you to
find why in the meantime.
So I'll see you next week.
Your homework is
going to be outside
so we can release the room.